our quandme éoute je VO Plô une Cu de
[Musique]
poulet
bien
Bou fait mais pas du
tout jeamène vers toi voilà ta droite
voilou quand même un pe
voil
[Musique]
bonhomme avancer
maintenance on voit bien
là
[Musique]
dou reste un peu làans regarde un peu ce
qu'il
autour on va tourner vers la
droite
tourner vers ta droite
ok pas
voilà
rap je suis oigé de recaler pour le
virageon est
[Musique]
virage bien
vertic
voilàber un
peu pas
travers pas
[Musique]
vertic
pas voil voil là vertic voilà là tu es
carrément
vertical doucement doucement
on dirait des cellules c'est
incroyable un me qui faisait de la
peinture en jetant des des morceau de
peinture comme ça sur
[Musique]
un
voilà fini sur un morceau serré zoom sur
un morceau sur un
truc reviens vertical un peu peut-être
non doucement ce c'est que je le
compense pour pas que ça accélère trop
[Musique]
donc tiens second tourne là on va
tourner vers la droite non non non non
Contin tout droit parce que là je
pourrais pas le en zoomant je pourrais
pas l'enrouler c'est beau c'est
vachement beau ça non c'est pas ch comme
les nuages chacun
pe gauche il est
voilz on y va
ok
cher
parce que ça la des textures vous en
aviez fait gauche à gauche comme c'est
beau de marron ouais
[Musique]
St mais tu vois là on a 60e un truc
comme
ça pour moi c'est la plus belle
découverte CIT vraiment l'ISL vraiment
c'est
incroyable
diversité diversité de paysage de
texture tout en c'est super beau vu com
elle est
belle trouver des formes
là
devant nous la glace est cassé au carré
comme j'adore je men un peu
[Musique]
doucement tout à
l'heuretureit tu ou pas on en a je pense
tris cassettes là
tt tu vasocher ce soir les 5 cassettes
et puis demain les pas mais pas malin
pas mal pas malin
mal
[Musique]
c'est beau parce que va voir là là elle
est toute cassé en rond devant nous vare
cassé au carré tu vas
voir c'est beau ça non
c'est magnifique ah voilà
oh là là regarde regarde cette espèce de
matière on sait pas ce que c'est tu es
où là c'est sublime
ça c'est où ça ah c'est à droite là
dessous à droite ah ouais ouais ça on va
le refaire bien ça ça c'est magnifique
ça on va on va le refaire ça ok
ouis qu'on tourne par la droite ou non
on on tourne par la droite ouis
ok parce que c'est beau ça
c'est B c'est un pe contre J aussi hein
t'inquiète
pas t pas peu
deed cette matière elle est inouie hein
ou là on a des rendus avec les les
ombres l'eau il a espèce de on dir un
bonhomme devant avec un nez et un œil
une bouche tu vois pas dira CAC
euh
je m'occupe attends je m'occupe pas de
Chirac
as bouge bien làdedans faut que ça
bouges
hein est devant toi regarde la tête tu V
pas envoyer la
bouche non laisse tomber laisse tomber
moi je vois tê super ça va pas c'est pas
grave laisse tomber c'est bon c'est bon
tu étais dedans tu étais dedans laisse
tomber laisse tombertais qu dans l'image
alors donc voilà on a encore voilà on
la on revient par là on revient par
là c'est magnifique C cette espèce de de
matière là c'est le soleil qui
va
on va passer audessus on va auessus on
va vers toi voilà comme ça
doucement voilà zo dessus c'est beau
c'est beau ça voilà c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique rentre dedans voilà
rentre dedans bien c'est de bien le
faire c'est
magnifique ça pe dire pour le ça va
marquer
ça
[Applaudissements]
on va faire GL maintenant ok son carré
c'est magnifque
ça
[Musique]
comme
Grandon
différen de matière absolument
incroyable
ok on laass ailleur
ser
[Musique]
ok j'aime beaucoup ça devant toi tu vas
voir prendre devant Mo intéressant
maisè glace qui est
cassé comme une V Ctait cassé c'est
devant
nous devant nous tu pas dedans du tu vas
voir non alors c'est ta tu es
là et là tuas en voir pas mal la glace
est cassé vraiment en rectangle quand tu
vas aller quand tu vas voir est tout les
droit a plus de rond
là tu vas en voir plein
voilà dira vraiment de la glace
doucement alors tu vois où il la plus
belle attends c'est l'impression que la
plus belle elle est
là-bas
[Musique]
regardeeorere ta gauche à ga
à
onait un petit cœur VO pas le petit cœur
en glace ah oui en B
ou c'est Mo
intéressante très contraste
làdessus
alors plus lar peut-être
ok ok allez on tour plus loin comm tout
à l'heure
allez
je rentre bien dedans surtout tout le
temps dedans comme tout à l'heure voilà
un peu moins serré voilà le petit cœur
voilà un petit
cœur un peu un peu moins peut-être quand
même voilà doucement très doucement qui
tourne voilà c'est beau espèce de
morceau de c'est beau non ah ou oui
c'est magique al je bouge un peu
là-dedans comme tout à l'heure
hein
un peu comm un de
[Musique]
caillouèce de
porcelaine
[Musique]
brisé on va tout droit tuasqu on va en
voir
d'aut
il bouge un peu làdedans on va tourner
très très doucementour là tu es bien
là reste bien dans le c'est ta gauche là
tu va
bien jours
c'estach
pas GAE gauche
[Musique]
voil
un
pe je pense qu'on
[Musique]
est pas
est
ouis pas de girage
alors c'est be ça
ou un peu que à l'heure mais
c'est
ch
al hotel
[Applaudissements]
lasedio
bien serré
a d'accord d'cord all làd en photo ça
para intéressant maisé trop serré pas
ser
comm organis l'impression tu
vois glace
brille
c'est vachement beau ça regarde moi
j'adore
ça pas non plus trop trop trop serré
mais